face aux coronavirus pas simple de s'y
retrouver entre les différents
dépistages à leur efficacité et c'est
bien là le problème est les tests pcr ne
serait pas si fiable selon les experts
plusieurs personnes ont été
diagnostiquées positive alors qu'elle
portait une infime quantité du virus et
ne serait donc pas contagieuse en
revanche il existe 20 à 30% de tests
faussement est négatif alors avec toutes
ses contradictions comment s'y retrouver
selon les chiffres du gouvernement un
million de tests sont actuellement
réalisés chaque semaine en france contre
700 milles et dom adhère au cours du
mois d'août
cela ne permet pourtant pas de freiner
la circulation de l'épidémie avec un
taux de positivité qui continue
d'augmenter
dépassant désormais les 5 % vous avez le
choix entre deux tests le naso pharyngé
dit pcr qui permet de dire si vous avez
le comique 19
le test sanguin permet lui de savoir si
vous avez déjà été en contact avec le
coronavirus et si vous avez développé
des anticorps pour remédier à la
saturation de plus en plus important des
laboratoires olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé a annoncé la mise en place
de tests au rapid antigénique qui se
fera également par voie nasale
le prélèvement est ensuite mélangée à un
réactif déposé sur une bandelette et qui
se colorent si le résultat est positif
le délai de réponse est rapide il
suffira de 15 à 30 minutes
un test qui pourrait être utilisée
également dans les hôpitaux et aéroports
le délai court pourrait permettre de
casser les chaînes de transmission mais
le test antigénique est réputé moins
sensible que les tests pcr olivier
verront le ministre de la santé mise
beaucoup sur ce nouveau mode de
dépistage le test antigénique pourrait
être bientôt disponible cette semaine le
gouvernement veut faire vite en
proposant de nouvelles alternatives mais
si les tests traditionnels ne sont pas
fiables à 100%
rien ne permet de confirmer que celui ci
le sera un autre type de test 10 à
l'hiver pourrait aussi voir le jour mais
les essais cliniques sont toujours en
cours